ah it's wonderful working in town with
so many creative talented gorgeous sexy
women and I have that enviable job of
getting close to one of them and
presenting her with an Oscar here are
the nominees for the best actress in the
supporting role Toni Collette in The
Sixth Sense
Angela
that's really key
Samantha Morton
even lowdown
blowing 70 employees comply
and the Oscar goes to Angelina Jolie
the first Academy Award nomination for
gilina Joanie
god I'm surprised nobody's ever fainted
up here oh I'm I'm in shock and I'm so
in love with my brother right now he
just held me and said he loved me and I
know he's so happy for me and thank you
for that and and so thank you to
Columbia
Winona you're amazing and thank you for
supporting all of us through this and
and all the girls in this film are
amazing and it would be everybody and
and my family for loving me Jeanine
Schreyer and your sister Michelle
Michelle we love you go Kosinski my mom
who's the most brave beautiful woman
I've ever known and my dad you're a
great actor but you're a better father
Hannah
Jamie yes you're just yet I have nothing
without you you are the strongest most
amazing man I've ever known
and I love you and thank you so much